this is a production of Cornell
University
hi everyone Welcome to My Country and
webinar series
um my name is Luis I'm a second year PhD
student in plant breeding genetics
Sacramento University in Larry smart
slab and once again our company by
Colonel alone Tommy Tony sorry Morocco I
want to say to me with this webinar uh
in this bus what what is going to be
like four sessions right now
uh I would like to mention again the the
this webinar series is a company of a
larger project called a well which is a
development of a educational curriculum
modules are sorry that would be
available on the Cornell ham website at
the end of the webinar series
excuse me X module will consist of a
recorded webinar an instructional slide
back and a set of high impact papers
pertain to perspective subjects all
webinars will be recorded and available
on the Cornell sips YouTube channel if
you're interested in rewatching them or
sharing them with somebody else
so with that I'd like to introduce Dr
Heather Darby she's a professor of
agronomy at the University of Vermont
and she has hosted a very nice home
conference two weeks ago and today she's
going to talk about her experiences
growing hiking of your hemp in the
northeastern U.S so great shot about
this and to hear more about it so
we offered you please talk to Derby take
it away all right well great thanks
everyone for joining today
and um as already mentioned I'm I've
been working on hemp here in Vermont
which is in the northeastern part of the
United States if you're not familiar
where Vermont is it's
a small state
um but very beautiful and we have been
able to
research hemp since 2015
once we were able to receive a permit
from the U.S government so our research
has been sort of developing
um over that time and I'll also say part
of what we do at the University of
Vermont is also work with Growers so
we're not only like conducting research
but the research that we do we want it
to be very applied and practical and
readily available to the farmers that
we're trying to help so for for most uh
people that are growing hemp it is a new
crop and it's also been really a new
crop to researchers
so there's quite a bit to learn
I've learned a lot myself over the past
six years now that we've been doing this
and I just want to share some of that
with you today just experiences and and
also research
okay so let's start with soil
so everything if you're growing outside
of course and even if you're not if
you're growing inside the growing Media
or
um if you're outside of course the soil
is obviously where we need to start it's
going to really a lot of ways make or
break
um the overall productivity of your
operation
so if you're buying a farm buying land
um it's definitely something you want to
pay a lot of attention to
um if you don't own land yet but if you
own land you really want to focus on
what you have and
um really make the soil so that it is
highly conducive for adequate Crop
Production
so we hear a lot about him being Wily
widely adapted to many climates which is
really true
um but in regards to soil
um it does require the highest really
the highest quality soil to for the
plant to be the most productive so a
soil that has really good physical
properties and good soil health and I'll
explain a little bit more about this
now one of
um the primary sort of limitations that
I've seen in growing hemp is that hemp
doesn't really like wet feet especially
when it's small when you first plant it
um or if you're transplanting when you
first put those transplants in the
ground once it's established it can
definitely tolerate
um wetter soils but in its initial
phases of establishment it's really
difficult to get a good stand of hemp if
you have very very wet soils and poorly
drained soils generally we find that if
you have 40 or more clay content in your
soil it's going to be difficult probably
to grow most any crop but um
uh but it's especially difficult to get
hemp established and of course there are
a lot of opportunities if you have clay
soil to basically create better
structure and drainage and also possibly
to use subsurface drainage or tile to
assist with creating an environment that
will be conducive for hemp production
and I'll say the the other piece here is
I guess I think a soil test right if
you're going to call a university system
and ask an extension person what you
should do to your soil probably the
first thing they're going to say to you
is do you have a soil
so get out and take a soil test a
standard soil test is cheap usually they
cost anywhere from 15 to maybe 20 or 25
dollars most University Systems
um will provide soil test services in
New York
um that's through a private lab in
Vermont it's through the University
so contact your University extension to
figure that out where you would send
those but it's it's worth the uh 15 or
20 dollars so that you can address any
underlying issues
um especially from a fertility
perspective but the soil
so pH is probably the first thing to
look at and hemp does require a pH over
six
and at least in the Northeast and other
parts of the world as well uh the soil
pH
generally either is below seven and
sometimes well below like it can be here
in the Northeast and then in other parts
of the country or the world sometimes
the pH is well over seven sometimes
eight
um and both ends of that Spectrum can
create some productivity issues so again
you want to try to adjust that soil PH
to be right around or over six so
ideally about 6.5 to 6.8 slightly
there we go so fertility requirements of
hemp
um are known so we know what hemp has in
its plant composition if we took the
plant and ground it up we would see
um what nutrients are in it and and sort
of what the composition is and what we
know less about for growing hemp at this
point are you know nutrient requirements
based on each individual's kind of soil
type or climate and that type of
information takes years to develop and
because we've only had you know a short
period of time at least at the
University system growing hemp in the
last 50 to 100 years we don't have the
best soil recommendations we could have
like we do for other crops but we do
have you know
um
I would say a well-educated guesses
around what we feel people need to be
doing to grow a high quality standard
okay so we know that hemp requires in in
good amounts nitrogen potassium and
phosphorus these are the macronutrients
so we know that hemp um is generally
composed of about three to four percent
nitrogen so it utilizes a lot of
nitrogen just like most crops
um two to three percent potassium
fires high levels of potassium and for
phosphorus it requires much less
um to grow adequately and it's about a
half a percent
um to about point six percent so if you
look at these kind of ratios you can see
that that crop is going to require far
more nitrogen and potassium than it will
phosphorus
so in general at least in Vermont for
potassium and phosphorus based on our
soil test that we've received from hemp
Growers uh we're usually looking at
about a 60 to 70 pound
recommendation per acre for both
potassium and phosphorus but again
that's highly dependent on a soil test
so we want to account for what's already
in your soil before we tell you to put
on more nutrients but again you can see
in general your crop is going to require
a lot of nitrogen good amount of
potassium in a much smaller amount of
phosphorus
it's really important for folks to
understand that there are essential
nutrients to growing crops
um and even though the we call these
macronutrients and you need them in
relatively higher percentages it doesn't
mean that you know adding nitrogen and
not adding phosphorus is what you should
do if your soil test comes back saying
that you're low and phosphorus and
you're high in potassium and nitrogen
but you don't add the phosphorus you're
still going to have production
limitations and both quality and also
yields okay so it's important to take
that soil test and understand
um you know the Baseline fertility of
the soil before you just start adding
things
because adding too much nutrients or not
enough can provide
um has a lot of challenges as the crop
has grown
all right so there's a lot of
information about nitrogen fertility and
hemp in the gray
um literature I guess so we do see a lot
of information out there
um and it's kind of hard to sort through
what's you know been sort of
scientifically researched and what
hasn't but from my own experiences
working with farmers and the research
that we've done we have seen and this
also is supported in the literature that
if you put on too much nitrogen to
higher rates it does stimulate the
formation of male flowers and I haven't
seen this in hemp being grown for uh CBD
or even THC where I've seen this is in
Rain grain hemp actually where I've seen
a lot of hermaphrodites being produced
when we've done nitrogen studies and put
on rates that are well over 200 pounds
of nitrogen per acre so again too much
nitrogen can lead to other problems uh
split applications of nitrogen are the
best that is going to minimize over
feeding at any one single stage but also
minimize uh the potential for loss right
so if you put all that nitrogen
fertility on before you even plant
um it's at risk of loss into the
environment and you know fertilizers are
expensive
so we don't want to do that all right so
deficiency of nitrogen in hemp causes
the entire plant to turn yellow and look
very chlorotic and um
it's really hard to bring those plants
back I have found so really have your
fertility strategy honed in and ready to
go before you put the plants in the
ground
um because once those plants get really
stressed it feels often impossible
so how much nitrogen are we talking
about and we have done some studies here
in Vermont in collaboration with the
University of Maine as well and really
what we have kind of found is that
fertilizing hemp being grown for
um CBD or flour
um or cannabinoids really does require
about you know anywhere from a hundred
up to about 125 pounds of nitrogen so
what that means is that the plant is
going to take up that much nitrogen that
does not necessarily mean that you need
to apply that much nitrogen to the soil
so here this is showing percent nitrogen
concentration and you can see at 125
pounds of nitrogen we maxed out the
percent of n in the actual land
um and that's what we're really trying
to understand because we know that the
hemp is only really going to take up
three to four percent of its total
biomass in nitrogen so we're trying to
figure out when does that Plateau how
much do we actually need to add
um to supply the plant with what it
needs
so this is our nitrogen research results
from this year in Vermont and you can
see we applied zero pounds of nitrogen
50 pounds of nitrogen 100
150 and 200 and these were split
applications so we didn't apply it all
at once like I already mentioned we
split these up over three times part of
the nitrogen going on before we planted
part of the nitrogen going on about two
weeks after we planted an additional
amount of nitrogen going on
about four to five weeks after
and you can see that when we hit about a
hundred pounds of nitrogen added
we maximized flower yield at a little
over four pounds per plant okay but we
also if you look at this orange line
um the percentage of flour out of the
whole total biomass went down which is
really interesting which means the plant
is actually also producing a lot more
leaves and stems so it's taking that
nitrogen and it's building biomass
and some of that biomass is flour but
some of the biomass that's being
produced is also more leaves more stems
Etc
but again as I mentioned really this
about a hundred anywhere between 100 and
about 125 is where we're seeing a
maximum response
and again
you know this is It's Complicated
because it really is dependent on
how you've treated your soil in the past
to determine how much additional
nitrogen you need to add but in general
if you're starting really at Ground Zero
this is what we're finding as Optimum
all right so you know there's been a lot
of question as well around if we
increase nitrogen rates are we going to
see spikes and THC and CBD
um and this there's a lot of has been a
lot of debate about this in again in the
gray uh literature where you know you
hear a lot about if you add too much
nitrogen the THC levels are going to go
up and if you don't add enough the THC
levels are going to go up we have not
experienced that we have been conducting
these studies now since 2018 looking at
fertility rates
um in uh have been grown for
cannabinoids and you know up to about
200 pounds of nitrogen being applied we
have not seen a spike in THC which is
what this data is showing this lower bar
you can see that there's no there's has
been no difference
um we also really haven't seen a
difference in total uh cannabinoids
either
right
um so
fertility very important start with a
soil test you don't know how to read it
reach out to somebody usually at the
University system there's also lots of
private crop Consultants there is
information on the internet too but make
sure you're going to a reputable Source
we have a website Cornell has a website
um so that you're making good decisions
around fertility management
here's a picture of some hemp doesn't
look so great this hemp here is actually
stressed out from its soil condition and
again when you're growing hemp if it's
starting out like this it becomes very
difficult to get it back on track so
starting out by doing your homework you
know preparing the land properly is
going to go a long a long way into um
success on your farm
so hemp does have a relatively long
Taproot if the soil is friable can go up
to six feet down into the ground
especially if you have really good soil
quality that I mentioned before so the
soil is very friable maybe even if the
lighter textured soil but soil condition
does really impact the the depth uh and
rooting system of hemp and doesn't other
crops do but hemp can be very
um efficient at securing nutrients
especially deeper down into the soil
profile if you create a good
um
soil environment so it also allows the
plant to access water
um which it may not be able to otherwise
access if the rooting system is is
really
so again just giving them the hemp a
really great soil environment will help
the plant become more
all right I have a feeling this is just
going to end up being a soil talk which
is important as I've already said
um and there's a lot to say about it so
we'll um keep going down this this line
I'm sure there'll be a lot of questions
as well so again there's potassium and
phosphorus as well
um needing a little bit less but still
really important nutrients
um we do know that
hemp uses most of its phosphorus at
flowering so more so than during the
vegetative phase so you want to make
sure that the phosphorus itself is added
not necessarily at flowering I would
actually say that adding phosphorus
earlier like even pre-plant is um works
out really well because you don't
necessarily lose phosphorus from
leaching in the soil and depending on
the source of phosphorus it might take a
little bit for it to break down or make
its way to the plant so you just want to
make sure that that phosphorus is
available at flowering make sure the pH
again is over six because if you have a
really low or really high pH it actually
will tie up phosphorus okay so again
most of the phosphorus is used during
flowering and you'll want to make sure
that you get that on early enough
um in the season so that it is available
to the plant at that time
if you're looking at your soil test
usually soil tests will say
um
you know if the amount of phosphorus or
potassium let's say is adequate or
Optimum and that's really your indicator
if you don't know much about soil tests
and soil test reports that you have
enough okay so if you're
Optimum in phosphorus on the soil test
or even high you definitely don't have
to add any more
okay so with potassium you need to be a
little bit careful with potassium it's
it's very soluble it's readily available
it also can leak very easily
um and the the requirement of hemp for
potassium is highest
um about four weeks after germination so
kind of um in that where we start to
move into kind of the rapid uh growth
phase of hemp and you again would want
to put the potassium on relatively early
if you need a lot of it you might want
to do a like a a split application and a
lot means you need 100 pounds
or even 150 pounds it really will depend
on your soil test you'll want to do a
split application a little bit about
half I guess a little about half at
planning and then you know the other
half a couple of weeks after playing
but you really want to make sure that
it's on the ground and ready for the
plant in the vegetative phase
um we have seen this where there's too
much potassium especially around
flowering or late in the season and it
can really delay
um maturity and that's in all crops you
know it's not just hemp
all right so micronutrient fertility now
we hear a lot about this in hemp people
adding all kinds of concoctions
um trying to you know add this
micronutrient and that micro nutrient
um so if you're growing in what we call
soilless Media so that would be you know
how you would be growing in a greenhouse
um or you know I guess maybe if you're
growing even hydroponically then of
course it makes sense to add a
micronutrient pack to that mix because
soilless media has usually has nothing
in it unless you've bought it with
nutrients
um out in the field again really
important to get a soil test here
because micronutrients are um
are required and they're essential but
if you put on too much you can kill your
plants you know they you don't need very
much so with nitrogen phosphorus and
potassium we're talking 50 60 100 150
pounds per acre with micronutrients
you're talking
pound an acre a half a pound a quarter
pound okay so very very very small
quantities and if you put on too much
again it can be
can be detrimental to the plants in more
ways than one hemp itself has a very
strong requirement for magnesium so you
want to make sure you look at your
magnesium on a soil test and also for
Boron so Boron is deficient in our
um part of the United States so I do
recommend that Growers apply Boron to
their soils with their other fertility
program at about a pound to two pounds
per acre but again that's very specific
to Vermont and so a soil test in your
area is going to help you define what
you need
um okay
so let's move on to
um varieties and I'm sure somebody in
this course probably has gotten into
this in depth but in my experience
purchasing seed
you know it's get it's gotten a lot
better than it was when I first started
but um you know it still is kind of a
little bit buyer beware you want to make
sure you're buying from a reputable
company companies now some of the better
companies
um and more reputable have been around
for quite a while
um have been around since 2015 2016 and
have an established business and an
established clientele
um they have a good reputation so you
want to make sure that you're buying
from a reputable seed source and even
though you know any seed
s or send sales person can give you a
certificate of analysis it doesn't
really mean a whole lot
um
you know as as Folks at least in the
United States know
um you know your crop is getting tested
and even though any Seed Company can
probably show that they were in
compliance
that doesn't necessarily mean that the
crop is always going to be compliant so
again just buying from a reputable seed
company is is really really important
um see quality still seems to be all
over the board and um you know
you know again reputable companies that
can provide uh germination rates and
have been in business for a while are
those that certainly I would recommend
um compliance is an issue you know
especially if you're growing for
cannabinoids and not
um high THC and you're trying to meet
regulations you have to make sure that
you're growing varieties that are going
to be able to do that and they're all
over the board so looking at independent
variety evaluation trials like the ones
we have at UVM and Cornell has and
others is important and again
looking at reputable companies and
here's you know information from our
variety trials
um this is just one year out of many of
the years that we've done these trials
you know there are varieties every year
that are not compliant and you know we
have to destroy them
um
I think again this is getting better as
we understand genetics
um and better varieties are being
developed and released and those
companies that are reputable
still in business and those that are not
tend to make their way
um
out of business
so again we offer a variety information
again it may be specific to you know our
region but many of these varieties we're
getting across the country much of the
seed from different companies so the
information is there
you can see that obviously they differ
widely in flower production but they
also differ widely in CBD or other
cannabinoid production as well CBG Etc
so here's um from our 2021 trial
um yeah 2021 we haven't finished 2020
and you can see the difference in yields
with the different varieties again this
information is available on our website
which I'll put up here in a second and
so you can get a chance to look at um
different varieties that are widely
available and how they
and here's uh the cannabinoid data
here's our website I can put that in the
chat afterwards we post all of our data
it's available every year
um one of the
things that we look at in our trials
which takes more time and effort but I
think if you're harvesting by hand and
even if you're not this is information
that's become really important to us and
it's looking at the flower to other
plant material ratio
um you know if you're harvesting by hand
and you have a plant that looks
impressive you know weighs 50 pounds and
you can barely get your arms around it
it's great for photo ops you know and to
send your friends and show them how big
your hemp plant was but when you start
breaking that plant down and harvesting
it by hand and end up with you know a
pound of flour and about 50 pounds of
leaves and stems you'll realize it's not
so cool anymore you know you're you're
almost crying because you just you know
can't get through all the leaves so what
we've really been looking at is we to
Broadway
um and you know it's really interesting
there are varieties that have far more
uh flower buds than they do leaves and
or stems and it makes it much easier to
harness especially if you're um hand
harvesting but you know depending on
what Market you're going for if you're
going for you know the smokable Market
or biomass these this kind of
information becomes
um much more important so again this is
all on our website and you can clearly
see there's there's strong differences
you know you can look down here at the
bottom where you know almost 30 percent
um
of the plant material was a flower for
this bottom variety and 70 was uh not 70
um another 40 percent was was Leaf
weight and the rest was stems
so we want varieties at least for what
we're doing up here in the top where the
majority of the plant is flower bud for
most people not everybody that's what's
being sold and has the highest levels
um
of cannabinoid concentration so here's
just a little bit of data again this is
from 2020 a variety like lifter as an
example is 45 flour and 25 leaf and on
the low end we had a variety called
Analee that was 19 flour and 47 percent
wheat so again this kind of information
is helpful for
for Growers
um and probably for breeders as well I
would assume all right so
um getting the plants in the ground and
started we've done a lot of this we we
um we've done direct seeding we've also
done clones and we've done
um transplants seedling transplants from
seed most now of what we do are
transplants direct from seed we've
stopped doing clonal cuttings
um I think that works for some people
but a lot more labor experience needed
um time
Etc to do that we can get really good
plants started in the greenhouse takes
about a month to do it so not very long
and you have to be cautious and watch
closely because they can quickly
um
become overgrown and when they become
overgrown and leggy
um that leads to difficulties with
transplanting and establishment so we
use deep Deep Cell trays to get more
Roots
um we blow fans on the plants after they
come up try to make those stems a little
bit sturdier you know you're trying to
pack a lot of plants in if you're
planting acres and Acres but when those
plants are you know closer together in
these cells and they have less room and
they start to touch that's when they
become elongated so you know there's
lots of ways to try to space things out
and make more
um you know robust a little bit shorter
plants for transplanting and those are
just a few of the things that we've done
using deep 72s I prefer deep 50s to be
able to get you know the best plants and
in one month it's not very long so you
know you gotta plan for field delays
um
as well and and this can happen in a wet
year or a cold year you know where
plants can end up being in the
greenhouse sometimes three weeks longer
than you had planned so these are all
considerations if you're starting from
transplant we have done from seed as
well
um especially
um
or day neutrals we've done
um from seed and you know this is tricky
we have had good good germ and really
bad germ
doing this
um and soil soil health is is sort of at
the bottom of this you can see we
planted twice
um the day neutral varieties and or and
um
you can see when we planted in June we
only had 47 germ we had a huge rainstorm
the soil got really crusted and
compacted which is what happened it was
in a poor part of the field poor part of
the farm sole quality was was low and we
saw the results of that and we planted a
second planting you know at the end of
July and saw a much better germ but we
had better soil commissions so are
planting from seed be very cautious
about where you're putting the hemp
because it is very very sensitive to
soil quality as it's emerging and
getting started
all right so transplanting ham
you know people may or may not have
experience with this there's a lot of
ways to do it by hand
um we do this mostly again you have to
be careful and patient and um
good plants from coming out of the
greenhouse work the best if they're too
leggy and thin or the roots aren't that
great it's just going to be hard to put
them in the ground and for them to
survive
you know if you're using a transplanner
you know like the one here
um you know same kind of thing you're
just really looking for Stout robust
plants to put in the ground to have the
best success these These are perfect
really in my opinion uh perfect size
these being a little bit long
have some challenges there you'll have
more loss you know get a wind
kind of just break right off
um we have done a little bit with
no-till into uh
rolled in crimp Rye
would say it's possible but we're still
kind of working out the details of this
and need some more more time before we
show you any results
a lot of people are still using plastic
mulch I think that's fine plastic molds
um has a lot of benefits especially if
you're in a cold area
like we are here in Vermont
um but requires more equipment requires
plastic
um and
you know not only is you know most
Plastics not a renewable resource but
you also have to get rid of that plastic
after the season is over
and where are you gonna put it you know
probably in the landfill
so there's some sustainability
you know questions around mulch
um there are biodegradable mulches and
things like that and again they all work
well and they have a lot of benefits but
you know hemp can grow just as well
without
um plastic mulch maybe even better to be
honest
um you know if you are growing in
plastic mulch
and raised beds you got to get you gotta
have irrigation as well because you got
to get water through the plastic mulch
and so that's a whole nother piece of
management
um gonna grow hemp because then you have
to have irrigation you have to have the
setup for irrigation and uh be able to
to water those plants under that plastic
this is another picture of transplanters
people transplanting hemp
some a lot of people are doing it you
can see the scale here lots of plastic
and again uh works well but also not
necessary
um you know without plastic you got less
input costs
um but you have other challenges you
know bare ground erosion weeds
disease all those things so you can grow
without plastic and the plants can grow
really well
if you have natural rainfall you know
you likely get enough rainfall to grow a
really good robust plant in most years
so you may not have to invest in
irrigation but um you know you can have
success both ways
um plant spacing spent a lot of debate
over this over the last few years
uh you can plant hemp close together in
our day neutral varieties we do two by
two uh two feet by two feet and you know
some people use a spacing of one foot by
one foot
um in our full season sort of photo
period sensitive plants we are still
using four by four feet or five by five
feet for the most part but people have
looked at everything in between and
again there are benefits
um to
any any plants facing it really depends
on your environment and what you want to
accomplish how you're harvesting
um what your end Market is but you know
you can see we get higher yields with
one by one because there's a lot more
plants packed into an acre but it's also
a lot bigger investment in seed
um for that return
and again you know it's also a lot more
plants to harvest uh potentially more
disease so you can see the unmarketable
yield that's there so again it really
depends on your goals for your business
what you're trying to do uh the
equipment you have whether you want to
pack those plants in there or you know
space them out far apart
um we do see a difference as well in um
CBD or um
I'm sorry we don't see any difference in
CBD production
um
based on plant spacing
but we do see the yield difference
okay
um let's see
let's see if we're looking at per plant
yields I'm sure this makes sense right
um with more spans with more spacing
each individual plant yields much more
um but there's more plants per acre with
a one by one spacing right so this is
per acre yields and this is per plant
so you're going for high-end smokable
Market you certainly want to focus on
you know this wider plants
um the benefit to a wider plant spacing
also we found or a slight benefit is
that we get more Bud
um and less leaves which is a really
good benefit foreign and with a shorter
plant spacing closer plant spacing we
get more disease
all right planning date and again we're
we're running short on time so we'll
kind of wrap up I think with a couple of
last items uh planning date here is at
least in Vermont we're looking at
optimizing planning dates around the
beginning of June
okay
um you can get decent yields if you
extend that planning date uh into mid to
end of June you can still get yields I
hear that from a lot of people but
maximum yields we get here if we plant
by the beginning of June
and these are from transplants that are
about a month old
and you can also see probably the
biggest difference and maybe the most
important thing
is with that longer
um growth period
we get higher levels of
CBD and other cannabinoids quite a bit
higher than delaying the planning date
right because these plants have a longer
period of time to be able to maximize
flower quality
all right so I know that
um we need to wrap up by about quarter
of ten of three and we're almost there
so I'll just talk a little bit about
irrigation and drought resistance
we do know that hemp can be resistant to
Drought once it's established so I want
people to remember that you got to get
the crop out of the ground or you need
to get those transplants established and
you saw the root system that's how it
can be so drought resistant so you need
to have a you need to have soil
conditions that allow for maximum root
to be able to provide the hemp with that
sort of level of drought resistance
because really the hemp itself does
actually require for maximum
productivity about 20 to 30 inches of
rainfall
so it does need abundant moisture
especially early on in its growth you
know once we get to flowering
um the need for water like most crops
um as flower set starts to go down
so you know as far as irrigation goes
um you know it's not necessary depending
on where you live but it can be super
helpful for establishment of the crop um
in particular but you know you also have
to be careful not to over water because
irrigation too much water can lead to
rots which you can see here in other
so we have seen a benefit with timely
irrigation to yields versus just rain
fed here in the Northeast but again it's
not necessarily we can still obtain
descent yields in most every year
without it but it can be helpful to have
irrigation available especially in a dry
year
all right the last thing I'll know is on
cover crops because I get a lot of
questions around uh utilizing cover
crops if if you have plastic mulch or
even if you don't there's lots of
opportunities to enhance soil Health
um in your hemp and we have grown all
kinds of cover crops between our hemp
rows over the years that we've been
doing this and you know cover crops can
establish very nicely especially when
you have a five by five setup or three
Fleet by three feet four by four feet
and you can get a really good cover in
between those rows
um if you want and there's lots of
options I think you know one take-home
message we can end on is
you want to make sure you have good air
flow so you don't want to be growing
some massive High tall dense cover crop
necessarily because that's going to
impede air flow
um you want to be a little bit cautious
about uh certain uh cover crops that
might attract pests that you don't want
on your hemp
um or diseases so you want to be
cautious about that we have actually
found a cover crop of annual rye grass
mixed with a low-growing uh white clover
and uh tillage radish works very nicely
for us but again there's a lot of
options here to include soil health
and reduce weed pressure
so I think with that we will end and
take some questions here I want to make
sure we have some time for for questions
um
and I see there's questions I'll start
with the ones in the Q a
since um that's where we're supposed to
whatever questions
um all right so
is there a soil mix that we can make at
home for starting seed indoors well
that's a really good question I have I
don't start my own mix I rely on others
to do that for me
um you just want to make sure that
um and I I caution people of this
because people will buy potting mixes
that sound really great but um don't
have enough fertility in them I actually
even grow a plant for a month so you
just want to make sure that you have um
and there's a lot of potting mixes out
there that are Blended now just for hemp
that uh would be good to start with but
you know you want to buy something that
does have fertility in it it's not just
peat moss or even
um
really overly sort of composted
materials
I would yeah I I haven't made my own
um
was recommended and pounds per acre so I
did go over that a little bit
um really I think for most people if
you're starting with a soil that has low
organic matter and again this is why you
need a soil
if you have one to two percent organic
matter and you haven't added any compost
or others organic amendments likely
you're going to need about a hundred to
150 pounds of nitrogen per acre okay but
if you have a very subtle fertile soil
with lots
um you know you've been adding compost
year after year after year it's likely
you would need very little maybe 50
pounds so it really depends on where
you're starting
um what about nitrogen rate uh for fiber
we have done those and I would say the
so far what we have seen is
um
nitrogen recommendations for all of the
hemp crops are about the same we have
done trials in Grain fiber and in for
flour and they are coming out about the
same you know that sort of 100 to 125
pounds if you have an organic matter
level of about three to four percent
which is what we have okay
um
did we use urea no we didn't use urea
um it depended on the year but we did
use a synthetic nitrogen source and the
reason we did that is because we wanted
to know that we were getting exactly
what we thought we were putting on and I
know there's questions around you know
worm castings compost but when you're
doing a nitrogen trial you want to make
sure if you're putting on 150 pounds of
nitrogen that is all available to the
plant
um what did we put on a at each
application really depended on the
treatment but uh we generally start with
about 50 pounds per plant of actual n
and then we would add from there
Maybe
are we talking about
cannabis being grown for cannabinoids
fibers or biomass so all the data I
showed you today was
um yes and we had we haven't seen an
increase soap I'm sorry
saying these questions I apologize
somebody is asking about the scientific
reason for increased number of male
plants under high end rates
um
usually when we see males being
expressed or any kinds uh often of kind
of these abnormalities
um it usually has to do with
some kind of stress on the plant so I
don't have a good scientific explanation
for that but
I would say that
um it likely is is some kind of
indicator of stress and you know the
plant wanting to reproduce and make seed
that's really probably what it comes
down to
how much sulfur does hemp plants need
and should sulfur be put down up front
so sulfur does Leach
so it's another nutrient that we have to
be careful about when we apply it
using a sulfur-based
complete fertilizer can be really
helpful so you can you if you need
potassium sulfur and magnesium all
critical in hemp production you can use
fertilizers like Sopo mag which is also
approved for use in organic and
generally about 25 to 50 pounds of
sulfur is what is required but again
soil test
all right
do we Harvest varieties early to be
compliant with the THC percent
um yes we actually track
um THC and CBD
um starting for us anyway about
um
three weeks after flowering starts so
that we can
you know figure out if we're moving out
of compliance so
you know we are at a university so we
have a little bit more leniency in our
work and part of what we're trying to do
is figure out
um you know when when crops and
varieties can exceed that level
um but yes I mean we have had to destroy
crops because they've they've gone above
the allowable level and
um
I think everybody knows that THC and CBD
you know they go up together
if CBD is going up so isn't THC so
um maximizing one
also means that you've likely you may
not have maximized THC but it you know
the longer you wait the higher both
levels are going to get to a point
so again look at our research data you
can see see those maximum levels for
many of the varieties
um
is that it no
Lewis is there anything you need to
cover or do we just keep going
um if you have a time who can cover any
questions yeah absolutely so
specifically
compared nitrogen rates for day neutral
varieties
um
I
this I'm making this an assumption
um but it's likely the same and I say
that because
you know they the plants will require
they may be smaller but there's
generally more of them and
um
you will want to fertilize for the
additional plants that sense so the
recommended rate is is probably about
the same
um let's see here
I I did answer the this question with
the larger spacing so the five by five
did we notice a difference in overall
cannabinoids
um we did not see a difference in the
cannabinoid levels between the plant
spaces
but there was a yield difference
um my other question is whether you have
ever observed increased male plants
under drought stress
uh we so we get
a decent amount of natural rainfall in
Vermont and what we often consider dry
by Vermont standards is certainly not a
drought by any means for the most part
so I have not
I can't say that I have observed
Even in our driest years in Vermont
which we've had a few growing hemp more
males
have not seen that
um are our research plots without
plastic molds some of them are and some
of them aren't so our plants plant
spacing study was without mulch our
Fertility Studies are without mulch the
variety of valuation is on black plastic
so usually or always when you're reading
our research reports it will
differentiate it will tell you which
trials are with and without Mulch and we
can obtain as I'm I said just as high as
yields with
or without mulch
how do you tackle an outbreak of
botrytus
question
and I I think you're you're going to
have somebody speak here on diseases and
Pest Management
ah
don't get desperate and and reach for
something this will be my advice don't
get desperate and reach for something
that is not approved for use
I will say that that's happened here in
Vermont
um
and I get it I'm a farmer too I own a
farm
um
I've grew up on a farm I know what it's
like to feel that those moments of
desperation in all different ways but
especially when you're about to lose a
crop
um and you feel pretty helpless and it's
money a lot of money invested time
effort all those things and um
yeah uh there are you know some products
and with all of these
with everything all the treatments
really that are available for hemp you
need to be applying before you see
botrytus and maybe people are
um but they're mostly preventative
measures
so we have seen I will say we've done
trials with different fungicides it's on
my website so go look at that
millstock which is a bike a bike car
bicarbonate material
um approved it's approved here in
Vermont for use on hemp it may not be
other places but bicarbs have for us
worked fairly well and for Growers too
and they're approved organic and at
least here they are approved in hemp so
but you need to check with your state or
you know whoever manages pesticides
area
um what kind of spray rig did we use
um we have all kinds of different types
of sprayers but I like our we have a
small backpack Air Blast sprayer so if
you're growing on a small scale costs
about 350 dollars
it does a really great job of covering
the plants because it obviously
again it's listed in our our progress
report online the manufacturer and the
sprayer but it's you know it's gas
powered so you know it's heavy on your
back it holds about three gallons some
material but it can spray a really fine
mist and you can get really excellent
covered on
and then other than that a lot of people
are using um like Orchard sprayers
um in their hemp
spraying
[Music]
um Harvest moisture and recommended
storage moisture yeah yeah I I didn't
um
I didn't get to that and I'm not sure
are you going to have somebody talking
about that Louis
sorry I was keeping track of the Q a no
no that's fine
um storage moistures
not somebody talking post Orange
uh yes there will be a person talking
about Harvest another person talking
about processing so that should be
covered in the next sessions okay yeah I
mean we try I will say we dry down to
eight percent
I
um I look at a hemp as you know
basically like hey I'm from dairy dairy
country you know so we produce a lot of
hay and if you're gonna store hay for
over a long period of time it's got to
be
um
around eight percent
for that now let me I think I answered
everything there
yep that should be all
right
uh well thank you so much Dr Darby yeah
and I'm sorry the I see some people
saying it was hard to um
hard to hear and I apologize for that
must have been my mic or my movement
yeah no worries I mean it would be
recorded I was able to hear you well so
hopefully in the recording it will be
better for all people and uh they can
access it on the YouTube channel the
Cornell sips YouTube channel so not just
this but also past and future webinars
uh thank you so much everyone thank you
so much larva it's a fantastic
presentation uh please join us in two
weeks for him for pests in hemp I can by
electricity Brit
thank you so much
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu